olá a todos
pra mim é um grande prazer poder estar
aqui hoje falando com vocês sobre
responsabilidade planetária que o meu
tema favorito quem me conhece sabe é e
eu sou muito feliz e agradecida pelas
palestras que vieram antes de mim porque
todas elas vão me ajudavam economizar
aqui eu tenho uma pedra aqui para
defender uma idéia é que é essa que está
exposta aqui o nosso mundo na verdade já
tem soluções tecnológicas econômicas
pessoas competentes informações
suficientes para a gente resolver os
nossos problemas
então por que eles não estão resolvidos
na minha opinião o que falta não é nem
dinheiro nem competência é a atitude que
eu estou chamando aqui de
responsabilidade planetária
eu tenho muita curiosidade desde criança
sempre tive de entender como é que as
pessoas aprendem como é que as pessoas
conseguem transformar uma informação uma
experiência uma vivência em algo
significativo para elas a ponto de elas
terem atitudes diferentes delas
modificarem a sua conduta e eu sempre
fico observando como que as pessoas
fazem isso como eu mesma faço isso no
dia a dia que tipo de experiência que
toca que promove esse tipo de mudança
eu comecei a pensar sobre isso mais
profundamente quando eu estava no meu
segundo ano de graduação na biologia uma
experiência que eu não me ei ali de vale
do ribeira foi um projeto de extensão
que eu participei durante esse projeto
de extensão a gente tinha uma missão que
era reduzir o índice de verminoses de
uma cidade em cidade de eldorado
paulista que fica na divisa paraná são
paulo o índice de verminose naquele
momento é de 100%
então vocês conseguem imaginar por que
que isso era um problema pra nós era
claríssimo que são um problema e aponta
da gente e todo final de semana pra lá
enfrentando 14 horas de ônibus em uma
estrada perigosa é e ter que ficar sem
dormir os finais de semana porque a
nossa universidade era no interior de
são paulo e isso era bem longe de lá
então nós começamos a trabalhar e como
estudantes que éramos diferentes cursos
diferentes áreas criativos fizemos tudo
o que pensamos que poderia ser do
interesse das pessoas para aquele
conteúdo será assimilado de uma forma
simples
fizemos circo fizemos teatro fizemos de
cana
fizemos levamos um microscópio até as
comunidades fizemos o que vocês quiserem
imaginava ea solução que a gente estava
propondo naquele momento muito simples
na nossa visão era simplesmente de que
as pessoas colocassem cloro na água elas
tinham a gente dava pra elas um tubinho
sim imaginava olha que custa botar umas
gotinhas de cloro já que não tem
encanamento nesta cidade e nem
tratamento de esgoto
então a nossa surpresa foi que nada
disso acontecia quando a gente chegava
lá nas casas o que a gente encontrava
era o cloro num lugar assim especial de
destaque né
como se fosse um quadro um presente na
sala mais usado mesmo ele não era porque
dava gosto ruim porque a gente esquecia
sempre tinha algum motivo
mas o motivo verdadeiro e foi aí que a
gente descobriu é que eles tinham uma
outra preocupação que era muito mais
relevante para eles a preocupação com a
própria manutenção nos lugares onde eles
estavam
essa cidade numa cidade de 14 mil
habitantes sendo 6 mil no centro eo
restante distribuído ao longo de 70
quilômetros em diversas comunidades
quilombolas
ao longo dessa estrada e por conta disso
não vou contar a história toda que hoje
a gente não tem esse tempo mas a gente
descobriu numa das comunidades um jornal
mural na parede que dizia assim cuidado
a cesp vem aí ea preocupação que eles
tinham na verdade era com a inundação
das terras deles com uma barragem que
seria feita na verdade sete barragens
longo do rio e eles se tornariam que
seriam então é retirados dessas terras
muitos já estavam sendo retirados e
ameaçado de não terem sequer indenização
o modo de vida deles já existia há mais
de 400 anos eram comunidades instaladas
ali que viviam da terra e principalmente
do rio então você imagina que tanto
culturalmente como materialmente seria
muito difícil de administrar
eles já estavam organizados em relação a
isso tinham conexão com o movimento dos
atingidos por barragens nacional e era
nisso que eles estavam focando e aí foi
nesse momento que eu comecei a entender
que os problemas não são só os problemas
que a gente vê eles estão articulados em
toda uma rede de relações e que nos faz
te perguntar que futuro é esse que nós
estamos construindo e como é que nós
vamos fazer isso faltando então no tempo
eu vou comentar com vocês a uma segunda
experiência já foi no último ano de
graduação que foi a experiência numa
ecovila em porangaba também no interior
de são paulo
aqui a preocupação deixou de ser é com
qual o futuro a gente quer o que é o
conteúdo desse futuro e passou a ser
como é que a gente faz isso como é que a
gente organiza a gente se organiza e
organiza as pessoas em relação a isso e
a ecovila tinha então todo um processo
de experiência que já seria um modelo de
sociedade proposta
então foi isso que nós vamos
experimentar uma série de estímulos que
possibilitaram entender como se trabalha
com inteligências múltiplas como se
trabalha em rede e foi aí que eu decidir
que o cursaria assim que eu me formasse
uma pós-graduação no rio de janeiro que
foi a única que existia naquele momento
com caráter interdisciplinar e que me
possibilita estava estar em interação
com o universo do terceiro setor com as
ongs
eu tinha feito uma listinha na minha
cabeça de diante da urgência dos
problemas ambientais quem seriam as
pessoas que
a gente precisaria mobilizar para que de
fato a sociedade como um todo se
mobilizasse e pudesse fazer a diferença
eu sou uma pessoa que não gosta de ficar
enxugando gelo
então eu fico sempre pensando qual é a
melhor estratégia como é que a gente
chega é de fato uma solução que não é só
imaginar é que pode ser concreta eu tive
essa experiência lá passei oito anos no
rio de janeiro e mércia nesse universo
do terceiro setor e trabalhando em tudo
quanto é tipo de projeto ambiental e
inserir na rede ambientalista por meio
dessa oportunidade e com isso eu passei
a fazer uma nova pergunta então se nós
temos pessoas nós temos recursos nós
sabemos qual é o problema o que está
faltando a educação ambiental que é a
minha área né desde 77 existe lá com a
sua carta de nascimento que é a
declaração de tibilisi e isso já era 97
então em 97 portanto 20 anos depois como
é que as pessoas ainda não tinham
conseguido fazer toda a diferença que
era necessária e foi então que eu tomei
contato com essa ideia da sociedade de
risco que me ajudou a organizar o
pensamento para resumir assim porque
isso é uma com um conceito mais complexo
mas para resumir a idéia é basicamente
assim tudo aquilo que a gente faz para
simplesmente sobreviver ou viver como
comer beber dormir nu se vestir morar se
transportar falar ao telefone se
convertem em atividades de risco a nossa
saúde
mesmo a nossa vida e as das outras
pessoas e outros seres
então o simples ato de respirar já virou
uma ameaça
essa é a estrutura da sociedade de risco
para dar um exemplo se a gente pensa no
consumo de agrotóxicos no brasil pra
país campeão do do mundo atualmente em
consumo de agrotóxicos
nós ingerimos aproximadamente 7 litros
de agrotóxicos por pessoa por ano
significa assim aproximadamente pegar um
tanto
esse e tomar alguém que você escolheu
isso alguém pediu me dá um veneno aí que
eu tô morrendo de vontade de tomar
eu acho que não eu também não e quando a
gente se depara com uma situação dessa é
isso que ilustra a sociedade de risco
não se são situações que nós pedimos que
nós queremos que nós opinamos que nós
decidimos mas elas estão aí e estamos
oferecendo risco tem uma série de outras
coisas que poderiam ilustrar isso mas
por oposição à sociedade de risco qual é
o modelo que a gente tem a gente tem o
modelo da sociedade sustentável
mas qual é o motivo de existir uma
sociedade de risco
eu vou resumir em uma palavra alienação
que a alienação vários níveis de
alienação alienação de si mesmo que é
aquela alienação do nosso próprio corpo
das nossas emoções dos nossos
pensamentos do nosso desenvolvimento
pessoal a falta de autoconhecimento a
alienação do outro que permite que
existam relações de dominação de
indiferença à alienação do mundo que faz
com que existam então consumidores
alienados políticos alienados eleitores
alienados trabalhadores alienados
cientistas estudantes alienados
o integrante da nossa biosfera alienado
enfim uma pessoa alienada por oposição
por oposição no qual é a relação
resultante dessa alienação toda uma
relação com o planeta que hoje é
utilitária é omissa e ingênua e
imediatista dominadora materialista
se a gente for resume-se numa expressão
a gente poderia dizer que somos
proprietários perdulários nos
acreditamos proprietários porque não
somos de fato mais perdulários sons uma
relação responsável com o planeta seria
o oposto disso contextualizada cuidadosa
e planejada integrada multidimensional
autoconsciente
nós seríamos todos colegas evolutivos de
um mesmo planeta
podemos então nos dirigir com as nossas
ações cotidianas
para reforçar essa sociedade de risco
tal como ela existe
voltada apenas para o lucro socializando
prejuízo e privatizando lucro ou para
uma sociedade sustentável que o foco é a
qualidade de vida para todos e todas as
pessoas e todos os outros seres que não
são pessoas todos então quais são as
sementes de futuro que nós estamos
plantando hoje no presente
nós estamos regando as da sociedade de
risco ou nós estamos chegando às da
sociedade sustentável tem como mapear
isso e uma forma da gente mapear isso é
ver o que significaria conviver bem com
o nosso planeta de fato considerando
todo esse nível de alienação que eu
mencionei em primeiro lugar reconhecer a
nós mesmos um processo de auto aceitação
do jeito que nós somos reconhecer o
outro seja esse outro humano ou não
humano reconheceu o nosso lugar na
dinâmica evolutiva do planeta enfim
partir do euro' nós para o mundo de uma
maneira contextualizada
o que eu particularmente estou fazendo
nesse sentido porque isso é um processo
não é varinha mágica que se aperta assim
resolve problema né então na vida
pessoal eu adotei um estilo de vida
limpa o mais limpo com sigo pensando em
diminuir rastros aí eu trouxe esses
vários objetos pra vocês darem uma
olhada as minhas escolhas são por coisas
que geram menos resíduos tem uma cadeia
produtiva limpa fomenta a economia local
ea gente pode é contribuir para
sustentar pequenas economias próximas de
nós que diminui o impacto ecológico e
diminuem também os problemas sociais na
vida social
tudo aquilo que nós colega falou aqui
antes de mim né
então você poder participar em coletivos
transformadores e nesse caso a
universidade nos favorece muito porque a
gente tem a oportunidade de atuar em
projetos de extensão e de pesquisa
o próprio voluntariado e o fomento ao
controle social que pode cidade
diferentes maneiras
mas a gente também pode falar de um
outro nível que seria o da vida
espiritual e nesse caso a gente pode
pensar em termos de cuidados próprios
pensamentos sentimentos relações
energias para que isto se torne mais
saudável
mas falando de mim eu diria que isso é
até onde eu fui né construindo essas
coisas mas nós aqui na tríplice
fronteira e estou destacando fosse mais
vale para atribuir fronteira todos já
temos uma série de iniciativas que se
fosse juntar todas para apresentar para
vocês já daria um livro de 500 páginas
o problema é que elas não são divulgadas
são pouco conhecidos fora do seu círculo
de atuação
então desde grupos de consumidores
ecológicos diversos projetos
comunitários de iniciativa de moradores
dos próprios bairros redes de atuação
por exemplo mais recente é a de água
florestas que têm se formado aqui
empreendimentos verdes cita o exemplo do
parque das aves e da pousada
agroecológica guataporanga construção
participativa de políticas públicas
isso tudo faz a gente pensar em termos
de equilíbrio entre dar e receber
o que nós recebemos do nosso planeta pra
começar um corpo ecossistema que tem
aqui mais bactérias do que células né
nutrientes dos serviços ecológicos o
prazer à beleza e tudo aquilo que
sustenta esse planeta ciclos
biogeoquímicos a biodiversidade etc
sustenta a nossa também então se nós
aprendemos a cuidar desses elementos que
sustentam a vida estaremos cuidando de
nós mesmos e caminhando em direção à
sociedade sustentável
o que você pode fazer pensar sobre o que
você devolve para o planeta o que você
doa pra ele como você agradece esse bem
recebido por exemplo nessa imagem aí do
mundo que vocês estão vendo bolinhas
quase brancas são as ilhas de lixo que a
gente tem no mundo hoje não temos mais
somente uma do tamanho do dólar
é como se divulgava pouco tempo atrás
não temos todas essas aí e aí a gente
pode pensar eu quero este mundo ou quero
este outro mundo bom aqui ainda é
desmatamento ea questão das de
destruição do solo
quero este ou quero este outro mundo que
é um mundo em que eu tenho é uma
produção agroecológica que abastece todo
mundo que é saudável que respeita o solo
que respeita às florestas que mantém as
árvores
eu quero uma cidade como essa que parece
um monte de favela o que era uma cidade
como a ecovila qual é o estilo que eu
quero eu quero uma cidade que seja
saudável uma cidade que seja alienante
então a gente pode se perguntar qual é a
nossa responsabilidade
qual a nossa responsabilidade tem a ver
com isso qual é o ato de responder é
responsabilidade
então a gente é capaz de sustentar as
consequências das nossas escolhas
isso é a capacidade de responder
responsabilidade planetária então é o
posicionamento ético da pessoa isso
exige reflexão que é decorrente do seu
nível de auto conscientização
multidimensional multi existencial em se
empenhar na teoria e na prática para com
a nossa saúde integral no planeta se
percebendo nesse processo retribuindo e
reparando aquilo que for necessário mas
pra poder fazer isso nós precisamos
entender o que gera a saúde integral e
quanto a gente está lúcido da nossa
participação na dinâmica terrestre
isso exige a gente se perguntar então
onde nós estamos qual é a dinâmica desse
lugar como agente afetado pela história
desse lugar e quais são todos os outros
seres e ambientes que participam dessa
dinâmica conosco passando aqui rapidinho
algumas imagens tanto da diversidade
cultural como biológica temos então
paradoxo para responder à nossa
responsabilidade planetária ela é como
visão sobre tudo isso ela é mega
fraternidade mas ela é também um limite
para aprender a conviver com toda essa
diversidade então eu encerro perguntando
pra vocês um rápido o check list como é
que vocês convivem com o ecossistema do
pará
o corpo das suas relações da economia
alienante do nosso teatro social da
nossa relação com as demais espécies e
com a biosfera com a nossa iniciativa em
renovar o mundo com a dinâmica evolutiva
o qq de prático nós estamos fazendo para
entender quem é esse mundo quem nós
somos e como podemos usar essas
informações para melhorar o mundo esse é
o meu convite pra vocês muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]